bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce premier
numéro de battles tech une série de
vidéo dans laquelle on va mettre en
faillite deux poids lourds de
smartphones bien énorme qui sont sortis
début 2018 d'un côté vous avez le honor
view dit ce qui est vraiment un
excellent produit que j'essaie il ya pas
longtemps et de l'autre le galaxy à lui
qui est aussi un excellent produit on a
regardé
lequel de ces deux produits est le
meilleur lequel a les meilleures
performances dans quels domaines et à la
fin on désignera le vainqueur c'est
parti
échauffement contre la gauche 30 et
percute direct donc on commence tu puis
vous avez d'un côté le haut review 10 de
notre côté le galaxy à huit c'est
vraiment deux smartphones énorme de gros
gros gros poids lourds de ce début
d'année
et au final lequel est le meilleur parce
que on doit faire un choix même si on
dit chacun est bien dans sa catégorie
malgré tout du point de vue du
consommateur
on peut pas acheter les deux os tout ton
derrière ça le fight on peut pas acheter
les deux il faut choisir alors qu'elle
produit acheté au nom de younis galaxie
8 c'est ce qu'on va essayer voir dans
cette vidéo alors c'est pas très
pratique de bosser avec des gants il
j'ai mes notes avec les gans un peu la
galère mais on va y arriver
pour cette vidéo va regarder ça en
plusieurs points premièrement on va
regarder du côté du design et de l'écran
pour voir lequel est le meilleur on va
regarder ensuite la puissance voire
lequel on a le plus dans le ventre et
lequel il plus intéressant
ensuite un point ils parent portant la
photo et la vidéo l' os
on va regarder ensuite un petit peu le
reste le bluetooth le nfc les choses
comme ça on veut aussi se poser la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
sont des points qui sont vraiment mis en
avant surtout par au nord enfin le prix
et au final on va regarder
lequel est le vainqueur lequel a gagné
ce match côté design moi je suis plutôt
un fan de samsung je trouve que c'est
plus sympa je trouve le côté plus
élégant le design quelque chose qui est
extrêmement personnel donc compliqué de
se baser là dessus c'est pas vous dire
que les honneurs view dit c'est pas bon
et pas beau c'est pas vrai ça serait
mentir
c'est juste une question après le
rapport aux produits moi très
personnellement je préfère ça me sens
mieux maintenant côté de l'écran vous
avez d'un côté pour le honneur view 10
en écran 5,99 pouces format 18 9e et en
face vous avez un écran 5,6 pousse alors
5,6 pouces oui mais du super amoled de
côté c'est une dalle psc du lcd donc
point de vue beauté de l'affichage point
de vue couleurs point de vue contraste
infini
mieux vaut avoir l'écran du samsung ça
dépend à près de vos goûts une fois de
plus si vous voulez profiter d'un grand
écran l'onudi strahl affaires marchent
bien c'est une dali ps qui est vraiment
belle et très optimisé mais c'est vrai
que j'ai tendance à aller plutôt du côté
du
samsung là dessus donc pour moi le
premier point va au samsung galaxy à 8
côté puissance stockage c'est là où ça
fait très mal
vous avez d'un côté le honor view 10
avec un k reen 970 cadencé à 2,36
gigahertz cij et diagramme 128 go de
stockage et face à lui le galaxy à 8
avec un exynos 7885 8 coeurs cadencé à
2,2 ghz à hertz tel giga de ram et 32
gigas de stockage de ce point de vue là
les odeurs view dit c'est quand même au
dessus mais au niveau de la batterie
vous avez une 3750 millan père heures du
côté du honorio 10 et du côté du samsung
galaxy à huit vous avez une batterie de
3000 millions perreur très clairement
pour la puissance au stockage les
performances le deuxième drone est
donnée aux honneurs view 10 et pas photo
vidéo
vous avez d'un côté le haut review 10
avec un double capteur à l'arrière 16
mégapixels en couleur et va les gars
pixels monochrome avec une ouverture 1.8
et de l'autre côté vous avez un seul
capteur à l'arrière pour le samsung
galaxy à 8 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 1.7 à l'avant vous avez une
double caméra de saïfi pour le à 8 16
mégapixels et 8 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 1.9 et un seul capteur à
l'avant pour le honor view 10 13
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 2.0
côté photo j'irai plus du côté du galaxy
à 8 notamment au niveau de la caméra de
celle fillon passe plus de temps à se
prendre en photo et immortaliser les
moments avec nos amis plutôt qu'à
prendre en photo des paysages de toute
façon dans les deux cas ça fonctionne
très bien la caméra arrière de honor vu
10 fonctionne bien même en basse
luminosité ça marche plutôt pas mal mais
je préfère quand même le rendu du
samsung galaxy à 8 du point de vue photo
parce que du point de vue vidéo c'est
l'honneur du disque il emporte avec des
vidéos en quasiment quatre cas alors
qu'on à se contenter d'un full hd plus
du côté du samsung galaxy à 8 au final
photo vidéo je dirais ex-aequo parce que
vous avez d'un côté de la vidéo qui est
très bonne dès la photo qui marche bien
quand même pour le ca pour le honneur
view 10 le samsung galaxy à huit est
vraiment bien pour la photo mais la
vidéo à voir un petit peu 4e rome va
regarder maintenant du côté de l' os sur
l'honneur view liste
v1 android 8.0 oreo alors que vous devez
vous contenter sur le galaxy à 8 d'avoir
à un android et 7 pour 1 pour un nougat
sur les honneurs view disent vous avez
un et motion 8.0 et sur le galaxy 8 vous
avez une expérience à 8.5 d'un côté vous
avez vraiment l'honneur du disque qui
est sur la dernière génération avec
l'android 8.0 oreo avec les motion nuit
de 8.0 l'emotion lui fait vraiment
penser à un plus
eyeos ça nous rappelle vraiment un petit
peu a coûté déjà vu pour eyeos de
l'autre côté l'android 7 pour 1 point il
ya est très connu l'expérience lui
fonctionne bien c'est vrai que pour les
nouveautés que le point à l'honor vieux
des civils tués deux ont du bluetooth
sauf que d'un côté vous avez du
bluetooth 4.2 pour l'honneur view 10 et
du bluetooth 5.0 du côté du samsung
galaxy à 8 pour la connectique toile 2c
de l'usb type c est vous avez du nlc le
wifi bien évidemment et la partie n'en
parlons pas un port jack de chaque côté
donc pour moi
du point de vue connectique donne un
léger avantage au samsung galaxy est de
8 côté accueil officiel maintenant ça
c'est vraiment un point qu'il y ait
énormément en avant par au nord honore
vraiment mettre en avant l'intelligence
artificielle et notamment force au nord
view 10 alors est-ce qu'au final
l'intelligence artificielle due aux
nordistes est plus intelligente que
l'intelligence artificielle du samsung
galaxy à 8 et s'arrête à prouver j'ai
trouvé en tout cas au niveau de mes
tests que l'intelligence artificielle du
point de vue du haut de leurs view 10
marchait très bien
les traductions ou les reconnaissances
de seine marchait bien la reconnaissance
de scène par contre dès qu'on découvre
qu l'impôt et que la scène devenue peu
plus complexe ça marchait moins bien
mais dans l'ensemble ça marche plutôt
bien
du côté du samsung galaxy et lutte avec
big division je dois reconnaître que ça
marche aussi
mais pas à tous les coups je galérais
parfois donc je deviens un petit peu l'
avantage du côté de l'intelligence
artificielle ou honorius mais peu à
double
en fin de compte il faut savoir que ce
soit le honorio 10 ou le samsung galaxy
est à 8
vous les trouvez tous les deux en
dessous des 500 euros 499 euros hors des
différences de prix en fonction de la
marketplace vous allez acheter
d'ailleurs je vous ai mis des liens dans
la description vous avez qu à ce sujet
mais gang box vers le bas je vous ai mis
des liens pour pouvoir effectivement les
trouver au meilleur tarif
d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse et des
liens d'affiliation si vous achetez par
ses liens ça me permet d'investir dans
du matériel faire grossir et shine donc
n'hésitez pas c'est toutefois à vous
intéresser à passer par les liens dans
la description au final tu es les
meilleurs lequel a mis ko lot entre d'un
côté le nord biodis et de l'autre côté
le samsung galaxy à 8 très clairement on
peut pas départagé de vainqueur y a pas
eu le chaos il n'a pas accepté une
grande claque dans la tête et qui s'est
couché
pour moi les deux se tiennent il ya une
différence si vous voulez vraiment de la
puissance à l'état pur si vous voulez du
calcul plus rapide si vous voulez plus
de stockage si vous êtes un gamer et si
vous voulez vraiment aller taquiner au
fond dans les performances
mieux vaut aller sur le honor view 10
qui répondra bien mieux si vous voulez
des vidéos de bonne qualité si vous
voulez aller plus loin au niveau de la
vidéo l'odeur view 10 sera vraiment bien
à faire maintenant si vous voulez de
bonnes photos des photos de qualité par
basse luminosité
si vous voulez de très très belles
selphy je vous conseille d'aller sur le
samsung galaxy a eu pour moi le match
est quasiment un match nul avec un léger
avantage quand même pour léonore gulbis
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que ceux au nord bio 10 août en
plus que galaxy à 8 est ce que vous
pensez qu'un à qui va coller un chaos à
l'autre dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire je vous invite bien
évidemment la sécurité parce qu'on va
pas être toujours plus toujours le du
high tech
on va faire un match comme ça de battle
tag pour essayer de comparer les
produits et voir lequel est le plus
intéressant par rapport à un autre
donc restez connectés je vous invite
bien évidemment à décéder pouces c'est
pas évident à laisser les pouces avec
des gants de boxe donc laissez moi des
pousse pousse vers le haut je vous
invite à vous abonner à rester connectés
parce qu'on ne surprennent plus de high
tech
d'ici quelques jours jusqu'aux mwc à
barcelone donc on reste connectés face à
voir plein de nouveautés plein de
produits ça va être cool merci beaucoup
à vous que sandra soyez sages n'oubliez
pas vous êtes les meilleurs
et à très bientôt
[Musique]